Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will be
my flash movie reverse flash deleted scene the
director was explaining a bunch about what's
going on with his character during the movie
or not going on because obviously we didn't see
him he also revealed to all the villains of the
sequel were going to be so I'll explain that too
even though we're probably not going to see those
sequels because of the box office probably going
to be the end of Ezra Miller as the flash as you
know it so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos so early in the movie we get
a flashback with Barry to his younger self and see
the events of his mother's death he's a little
kid just hanging out with his mother you notice
he's wearing a mystery machine t-shirt which is
actually an Easter egg for James Gunn even if
they didn't intend it on purpose Andy muschietti
probably didn't know that James Gunn was going to
become his boss when they were filming this scene
because James Gunn wrote the original Scooby-Doo
live action movies their couple Easter eggs for
reverse flash early on here he's wearing yellow
also the younger version of Barry from 10 years
ago is wearing yellow throughout the movie for
the most part then a short while later when his
father goes to get the can of tomatoes that his
mother forgot he's is playing in his room and all
of a sudden is dead silent and you just hear his
mother scream and tear and they find her with the
knife inside of her a lot of people wondering who
killed her and the director confirmed it was
supposed to be reverse flash as a lot of us
believed even though the dark flash like the evil
future version of younger Barry claimed that he
created a bootstrap Paradox by throwing him into
10 years ago so that he would eventually create
dark flash that dark flash didn't also kill his
mother as part of that whole bootstrap Paradox
it really was just an unseen reverse flash during
the movie so the actual circumstances for how he
killed Barry's mother are a little bit different
from The Flash TV show because they've done many
different versions of all the stuff they did in
The Flash movie on The Flash TV show in fact dark
flash is basically like a savitar version of Barry
the way they explain how dceu reverse flash kills
Barry's mother in the movie is the way you see him
peeking his head out of the speed force out of the
Chrono Bowl into other time periods like earlier
in the movie when he's looking at the babies from
his earlier save and he just pokes his head out
basically like his head is sticking out in this
time period and that's it no other part of his
body is touching anything else in this time period
This is how reverse flash killed Barry's mother
without creating any sounds when he was upstairs
and you just hear his mother scream what happened
is reverse flash just stuck his hand out grabbed
the knife stabbed her and then pulled his hand
back into his own Chrono Bowl really it's the
speed force but they kept calling it The chronobo
in the movie so this is why there was no evidence
of reverse flash anywhere in that crime scene he
was wearing gloves so there were no fingerprints
on the actual blade and no other part of his body
touched the ground so there were no other evidence
of anything being moved around his mother just
turned around and saw a random hand sticking out
of the speed force like what the hell is going
on as it grabbed it and stabbed her during the
comics and during The Flash TV show that event
was a little bit different because reverse flash
entire body was in that room so you actually
see him running around inside the room doing
it here's the real rub though if Barry flashed
back to his mother's death and is witnessing this
that means he already experienced the timeline
where reverse flash killed his mother which is
technically the second version of The Flash's
timeline so while the dceu movies Man of Steel
Batman v Superman the Justice League Snyder cut
were all taking place in that second version of
the timeline they got real deep into the Weeds on
this concept during The Flash TV show where Barry
keeps going back to the night that his mother died
and you're always wondering what was happening in
the original flash timeline because the events
of the TV show when they first pick up in the
pilot episode are basically the beginning of the
second version of the timeline but that original
flash timeline is very similar to The Flash TV
show's original timeline with the Grant Gustin
Flash the only thing that was really different in
that second timeline that we saw in all the dceu
movies for his character was the timing of when
Barry became the Flash and some of his actions
in the future but obviously one of the big things
is that things didn't change in that new version
of the timeline so much that eel barthon did not
become reverse flash like he didn't affect his
own timeline that much and that was the whole idea
reverse flash was trying to to prevent Barry from
becoming the flash by killing his mother assuming
that the tragedy would just break him so much that
he wouldn't be able to do anything what really
winds up happening though is they catalyzes Barry
and accelerates events so he becomes the flash
much earlier in the timeline so we're talking
about the dceu movies causing him to become the
Flash before the events of the Man of Steel movie
things play out as we saw them during the dceu
movies eventually he travels to the Future and
has his encounter with eobard thawne when he first
became the flash their meeting goes very badly
and eobard thawne turns evil calling himself
reverse flash and just continues to go back
in time to try and mess with Barry they actually
dealt with the version of this event during The
Flash TV show in the final couple of episodes
the original eobard thawne flash came back and
they tell a version of the comic book story
what happened is that ubarthon grew up in the
25th Century The Flash didn't exist anymore but
he read stories about him comic books so to speak
about the Flash's adventures and grew to love him
and wanted to be like the flash so we found a way
to recreate the accident that gave Barry Powers
making himself a version of The Flash and during
his very first attempt at using his powers
to save a bunch of people Barry inadvertently
travels from the past to his timeline and
winds up saving the people before Eobard
Thawne can and that just drives him to become
evil it was my turn I was supposed to be the
hero you're the villain flash you're the one who
reversed my entire life and dragged me into hell
there's also a version of this story where reverse
flash also travels back into the past and goes to
the flash Museum and learns of his fate to
become Professor Zoom he learns that he's
supposed to become a flash villain he then goes
insane with the knowledge and it winds up being
a self-fulfilling type of Prophecy where he sees
his future and ultimately does things that lead
to that future during the flashpoint version of
events he feels like he's found a way to change
time so that things won't play out the same way
without completely erasing himself from existence
if that winds up being killing Barry's mother he
turns into the world's worst toxic Fanboy with
superpowers like a bright burn situation and vows
to destroy Barry's life and just continues to try
different methods over the years so it sounds
like because they were going to actually cast
a version of reverse flash for the sequel we would
have seen a version of that origin story like they
would have shown you what happened in the 25th
Century and how he became the Flash and then
became the reverse flash still think that Anthony
Starr would probably be the perfect version of
that character the other sequel villains that
Andy muschietti said that they had planned to
do were the turtle and Gorilla Grodd so obviously
Gorilla Grodd really big character turtle is also
one of the OG flash villains they did versions
of those on the Flash TV show they did pretty
much every classic flash Rogue on The Flash TV
show it sounds like if they had made it to a
Trilogy as most movie studios plan for movies
like this the third movie would have been him
against the classic flash Rogues like Captain
Cold and Heatwave there was an early version of
this movie when the directors were changing his
there were like four different directors before
Andy muschietti came on a couple of those early
directors had versions of The Flash movie where
he didn't do a lot of time traveling and it was
just the flash Rogues in the movie they didn't
come up with the whole Batman idea the whole flash
point idea during the movie till much later in
the process when Andy muschietti was hired but I
think it's pretty safe to say there's no way Ezra
Miller is coming back James Gunn said before the
movie came out you know if he's coming back we'll
just have to wait and see what she was talking
about the box office if the movie had made over
a billion dollars they probably would have thought
a little bit harder about bringing him back but I
think it's gotten the way of the Black Adam movie
where it doesn't live up to standards and they're
probably never going to come back at least anytime
soon and if he does come back it'll be like Henry
Cavill coming back as Superman where it's in like
a crisis on infinite Earth's big Multiverse movie
in the next like seven or eight years either way I
think most people will be fine with them recasting
Ezra Miller after all this has gone down like
okay movie did not do great I mean they're going
to recast okay everybody's making their piece with
it the other big thing they revealed too is there
was a live-action Batman Beyond movie that they
were developing for Michael Keaton and it was
dependent on the box office of The Flash movie
had it been big Enough Michael usland who's one
of The Producers that's been on the Batman movie
since the original Batman 1989 movie has a son
who claimed to Kevin Smith as he says that there
was a Batman Beyond movie that they were going to
make if The Flash movie made enough money I did a
video about this live-action Batman Beyond movie
a little while ago but the whole idea is that most
people believe that when James Gunn was hired and
rebooted DC moves or decided to reboot DC movies
that's when they canceled that live-action Batman
Beyond movie so either Michael usland's son was
just mistaken and they had always planned on
rebooting and not doing live-action Batman Beyond
or they were still thinking about it just waiting
to see how much money The Flash movie made because
they brought Michael Keaton back like oh if people
love him enough maybe we will make it no matter
what's going on with the reboot and we'll just
call it an else rolls movie either way I am kind
of sad not doing that because Michael Keaton's
Batman was great in the movie and I talked about
this during my previous videos but I feel like
of all the things that Andy moussieri did in
the movie his treatment of both the versions
of Batman Ben Affleck Batman and Michael Keaton
Batman were probably one of the best thing things
that he did in the movie which is why James Gunn
gave him the job directing Batman brave in the
Bold with obviously a new recast version of Batman
that they haven't announced yet like oh you could
do big event movies and you're really good at
doing Batman so why don't we give you the next
Batman movie either way if you have not seen The
Flash movie now they're doing a fire sale because
of what's happening with ticket sales and doing
like a buy one get one free so they're basically
giving Flash Tickets away for half off I don't
know if this is in every country but at least
in the United States there were a whole bunch of
other deleted scenes alternate endings involving
Henry Cavill Superman a bunch of other Justice
League characters alternate post credit scenes
I just did a video on that you can click here
to learn about all those and click here to
learn about Ben Affleck of all people coming
back in Deadpool 3 as his version of Daredevil
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!